Speaker 1: All right, let's hit a couple of other
small stories related to the politically violent
right wing attack on Paul Pelosi, Nancy Pelosi's
husband. I continue to really like the tone and
tenor of California Democratic Governor Gavin
Newsom's analysis of a lot of these realities
of the modern right wing. He has been talking
about this for a long time. He has been talking
about these are this is a violent movement
in many ways. And January six proves that so
many different events prove that. And he was
interviewed on KPIX five and he is making a
stochastic terrorism argument here. I'm so
glad that he is doing that. He is saying,
look at what they put out on social media,
look at what they put out at rallies,
look at the language that they
use. Of course, people are going
to start committing violence on their behalf.
Speaker 5: Don't tell me that's not aiding and
abetting all this. Of course it is. There's want
to see to create a culture, a climate like this.
I mean, look online, look at the sewage that is
online that they amplify on these networks and
in social media to dehumanize people like
Nancy Pelosi and other political leaders.
Governor Newsom also said he's no stranger to
threats, but says he believes things are getting
worse. There is no principle. I know what
over the last three years. Come on my inbox.
Trust me, you don't because I'm not
sharing it. I don't share with my wife.
I've got four kids, so I know a little bit about
this. I mean, it wasn't just a recall against me.
It was surround sound in every way, shape or form.
So love this venom at a level I've had a look
all at. There's always folks in the extreme and
you roll your eyes. It's just the sounds with the
arena. But this is different. This is something
different here. There's, you know, the mind is
being stressed. People feel free to shut again.
Speaker 1: That's exactly right. You know,
we all talk about it. Folks in left wing
media like me, all the usual suspects. If
you watch any of, you know, our other
shows, if you're in this ecosystem,
we all get it to different degrees. Certainly
if one is Jewish, you get more of it. We're
seeing that for sure. But Gavin Newsom is
completely right. What do you expect to happen?
When you create for years, year after year after
year, a culture, an environment in which this type
of violence is encouraged. Sometimes it's overtly
encouraged. But sometimes it is more implicitly
encouraged. It's not come around. It's. I'll pay
your legal fees. It's targets on their backs,
in ads. It's someone's got to really show up
and show, Nancy. Just recently, Trump at a rally
and others were specifically targeting her. So
it's going to have an impact. And if it didn't,
they wouldn't be saying it. And then the
other really horrifying, horrifying thing
that we have to understand is. Their violent
rhetoric encourages and causes the violence.
When it then happens, then they use it to justify
more violence by saying, listen, it's both sides
are being very violent, antifa, BLM and then
justifies hey, we're just being as violent as
they are, even though it is, of course, completely
untrue statistically. I gave you the data earlier.